à la recherche de sécurité thomasolverda
Ortis et débarqué à Montréal il y a une
semaine
après avoir économisé pendant deux ans
il s'est payé un billet d'avion pour
quitter le Mexique et venir faire une
demande d'asile ici
il veut travailler il est loin d'être le
seul
ils sont nombreux à être hébergés ici au
YMCA dit-il depuis le début de l'année
près de 8000 mexicains ont demandé
l'asile au Canada dans les aéroports
canadiens plus de 80% d'entre eux l'ont
fait à l'aéroport Pierre-Elliott Trudeau
à Montréal un processus régulier
contrairement à la braise du chemin
Roxane mais qui semble organiser selon
cette intervenante on a ressenti qu'il y
a un certain structure évidemment qui
est là est-ce que c'est un système de
passeurs est-ce que c'est un système
boucherie très amical on a aucune idée
il arrive avec un objectif clair
travailler mais pour l'objectif est
d'abord la sécurité
avoir un permis de travail pour éviter
de venir ou fardeau
la position géographique les vols
directs entre Mexico et Montréal font
partie des pistes de réponse avancées
par ces intervenants pour expliquer
pourquoi leur arrivée maintenant pour le
NPD c'est toutefois la preuve des fêtes
du système d'immigration économique
c'est comme si ces gens-là savaient très
bien que notre système d'immigration
d'immigration économique et tout proche
et chaotique les retards sont
épouvantables mais depuis 2016 le
gouvernement Trudeau a aussi aboli
l'obligation des visas pour les
Mexicains
trois questions pour le moment dit le
ministre fédéral de changer le système
de visa thomas lui est conscient qu'il
pourrait devoir retourner au Mexique si
ça demande et refusée un risque qu'il
est prêt à prendre ici Jacques Audric
Charbonneau Radio-Canada Montréal